tengo un círculo aquí y están marcados
dos puntos este punto digamos que tiene
un color digamos como marrón es el
centro del círculo y el punto azul es un
punto sobre el círculo así que con esta
información te invito a que hagas una
pausa y trates por tu propia cuenta de
hallar la ecuación de este círculo
muy bien ahora vamos a hacerlo todos
juntos muy bien y pensemos primero en
quién es este punto de aquí bueno pues
este punto que es el centro tiene
ciertas coordenadas verdad de hecho su
coordenada en x es menos 1 y su
coordenada en que es 1 así que vamos a
escribir esto tenemos que el centro de
nuestro círculo tiene coordenadas menos
1,1 muy bien aunque ya entonces esto fue
para el centro ahora veamos qué es lo
que ocurre con el radio muy bien y
recordemos que el radio es es la
distancia del centro a cualquier punto
del círculo verdad en particular
podríamos ver qué ocurre con la
distancia de este centro bueno desde el
centro a este punto azul que tenemos ya
marcado así que vamos a trazar digamos
radio vamos a hacerlo un poquito más
grande
entonces vamos a trazar este radio y
esta es la distancia que queremos
calcular verdad para encontrar el valor
del radio de esta circunferencia verdad
entonces para calcularlo necesitamos
construir un triángulo rectángulo y
usaremos la fórmula de la distancia
verdad entre dos puntos que
esencialmente proviene del teorema de
pitágoras muy bien entonces vamos a
construir este triángulo rectángulo
vamos a trazar esta línea aquí verdad y
esto nos va a representar nuestro cambio
en x y vamos a trazar otra línea vamos a
trazar otra línea que representa nuestro
cambio en ye y por supuesto recordemos
que este este triángulo perdón es
rectángulo verdad es decir aquí se forma
un ángulo de 90 grados entonces gracias
al teorema de pitágoras lo que tenemos
es que el radio al cuadrado que es esta
distancia que queremos
calcular verdad es el radio del círculo
el radio al cuadrado será igual al
cambio en x el cambio
cambio en x elevado todo esto al
cuadrado más el cambio en el cambio y
también elevado al cuadrado verdad y
esto es esencialmente por el teorema de
pitágoras así que vamos a calcular quién
es el cambio en x y el cambio y así que
aquí tenemos el cambio en x bueno
esencialmente tenemos que ver cuántas
unidades hemos avanzado en esta
dirección verdad es decir lo podríamos
ver como el x final verdad que sería 6 -
en la coordenada x de este punto que
sería menos 1 verdad
6 - menos 1 que esto nos da un total de
7 muy bien aquí tenemos nuestro cambio
en x esto será 7 muy bien ahora veamos
quién es el cambio en el cambio pues
nuevamente tendremos la coordenada en
jet de este punto que será menos 4
y luego restamos la coordenada y de este
punto verdad que sería menos 1 muy bien
entonces menos 4 menos uno nos da menos
5 verdad ahora también podríamos pensar
por ejemplo en la distancia o la
longitud de este segmento verdad lo
único que tendríamos que hacer es tomar
el valor absoluto de todo esto verdad y
nos daría 5 por ejemplo pero eso no
importa porque vamos a elevar al
cuadrado así que da lo mismo si dejamos
5 menos 5 muy bien entonces nuestro
cambio en x resultó ser 7 y nuestro
cambio en y resultó ser menos 5 verdad
entonces tendremos 7 al cuadrado nos da
era 49 más menos 5 al cuadrado pero
menos 5 al cuadrado es 25 muy bien
entonces tenemos 49 25 podemos concluir
que el radio al cuadrado será que serían
74 serían 74 muy bien
es decir si nosotros queremos saber el
valor del radio nada más pues será la
raíz cuadrada de 74 así que la ecuación
del círculo serán todos por todos los
puntos x
tales que disten esta cantidad del
centro entonces cómo podríamos
representar esto en términos algebraicos
bueno esto será simplemente x menos la
coordenada del x del centro que será
menos 1
todo esto va elevado al cuadrado más más
y menos la coordenada del centro que es
- 1 y esto al cuadrado nos debe dar el
valor del radio al cuadrado pero el
radio al cuadrado es 74 74 entonces
todavía esto lo podríamos simplificar un
poco más verdad aquí sería x menos menos
uno nos da x más uno al cuadrado más que
menos uno
- 1 al cuadrado y esto nos debe dar 74
todos los puntos x que satisfacen esta
ecuación son los puntos de esta
circunferencia y hemos terminado